hallar la pendiente de una línea que
está dibujada en esta gráfica así que la
pendiente de una línea está definida
como lo que se eleva a entre lo que
corremos digamos o también lo puedes ver
como el cambio en cambio en g
/ / el cambio cambio en x y déjenme
mostrarles lo que esto significa así que
vamos a empezar con un punto arbitrario
en esta línea y están digamos
seleccionados o resaltados con puntos
gordos así que si queremos empezar en
este punto
digamos que queremos hallar cuál es
nuestro cambio en x en la dirección
positiva baja queremos ir de este punto
a este otro punto okay cuanto nos
movemos en x así que si nos movemos en x
digamos hacia la derecha estamos yendo
desde menos 3 a 0 así que vamos desde
menos 3 a 0 ok
así que nuestro cambio en x que este es
delta x
nuestro a delta x es igual a 3 aquí el
cambio en x es 3
y ahora cuál es nuestro cambio y si
nuestro cambio en x fue 3 ok bueno pues
nos movemos
sí sí nos movimos tres en equis a la
derecha cuanto nos movemos en y bueno
pues realmente nos movimos hacia abajo
fuimos de tres a dos así que hicimos un
cambio en y hacia abajo así que nuestro
cambio es menos 1 ok
tuvimos una digamos que el cambio fue
menos un ok y el camión x fue igual a 3
muy bien entonces al final lo que fue la
pendiente nuestra pendiente fue menos un
tercio
déjenme ponerlo con esto déjenme moverlo
entonces la pendiente fue menos un
tercio y lo que quiero hacer ahora es
mostrarles que la pendiente no depende
de la elección de los dos puntos que me
tomé por ejemplo vámonos ahora a ir de
este otro punto de abajo y movernos
hacia atrás al punto de arriba porque
entonces si voy de este punto al punto
más alto cuál fue nuestro cambio en x
bueno nuestro camión x es todo esto
esto de esta distancia de aquí nuestro
cambio en x es ir de tres a menos tres y
nos fuimos en seis unidades pero hacia
atrás así que nuestro camión x fue menos
seis ok delta x en este caso es menos
seis ahora sí del cte x es menos seis y
regresamos a este punto inicial cuál es
nuestro cambio y para llegar a ese punto
entonces bueno estábamos en iguala 1 y
subimos hasta allí igual a 3 por lo
tanto este cambio fue positivo porque
subimos baja y fue un cambio de dos
unidades así que del taller es igual a 2
ok la pendiente es el cambio de y entre
el cambio de x correcto entonces nuestro
camión y simplemente fue
cuando subimos o bajamos en la dirección
vertical nuestro cambio en x es cuanto
nos movemos en la dirección horizontal y
la pendiente nos queda 2 / menos 6 que
es también menos un tercio y podrías
verificarlo tú mismo tomate ahora estos
otros dos puntos empieza en cualquiera
de estos digamos en este y
llegas a este último punto así que para
cualquier línea de déjenme hacerlo de
nuevo tenemos aquí un cambio en x en
este caso nos movimos 3 en la dirección
positiva así que tenemos el cambio en x
igual a 3 y el cambio fue negativo
verdad bajamos tenemos un cambio en jet
de menos 1 porque bajamos así que la
pendiente nuevamente es menos un tercio